principles for success an ultra
mini-series adventure in 30 minutes and
in eight episodes episode 7 be radically
open-minded taking risks and
occasionally being ruined wasn't
acceptable and neither was not taking
risks and not having exceptional results
I needed an approach that would give me
the exceptional upside without also
giving me the exceptional downside when
I discovered it it turned out to be my
Holy Grail to get it I needed to replace
the joy of being proven right with the
joy of learning what's true this need
prompted me to seek out the most
thoughtful people I could find who
disagreed with me I didn't care about
their conclusions I just wanted to see
things through their eyes and to have
them see things through my eyes so that
together we could hash things out to
discover what's true in other words what
I wanted most from them was thoughtful
disagreement going from seeing things
through just my eyes to seeing things
through the eyes of these thoughtful
people was like going from seeing things
in black and white to seeing them in
color the world lit up that's what I
realized that the best way to go through
the jungle of life is with insightful
people who see things differently from
me think about the five step process I
described earlier as I said because we
are wired so differently not everyone
can do all the five steps well but you
don't have to do them all alone you can
get help from others who are good at
what you're not who are wired to
perceive things you can't all you need
to do is let go of your attachment to
having the right answers yourself and
use your fear of being wrong to become
open-minded to these other views
in this way you could point out the
risks and opportunities that you would
individually miss I found that taking
this radically open-minded approach and
believability weighting people's
thinking significantly increased my
probabilities of making the best
decisions possible this enabled me to
ascend to greater heights and greater
challenges in the past I would have
always wanted to do what I myself
thought was best but now I sort out the
strongest independent thinkers I could
find I still do there is nothing better
to be on a shared mission with
extraordinary people who can be
radically truthful and radically
transparent with each other
this approach led me to create a company
with the unique idea meritocracy
operating in a unique way that produced
unique successes in an idea meritocracy
you get the best of everybody
everyone thinks independently then we
work through our disagreements to get at
what's best however not every opinion is
equally valuable and we had to learn to
distinguish between good ideas and bad
ones to get the best decisions in other
words we needed to believability way to
people's thinking but that's another
story I will explain in my work
principles right now there are many
wonderful opportunities and dangerous
risks surrounding you that you don't see
if you saw them free of the distortions
produced by your ego or your blind spots
you would be able to deal with them more
effectively if you could acquire this
ability and with practice you can you
will radically improve your life in
episode 8 I will conclude our short
journey together with a few practical
thoughts so that you can begin your own
journey toward whatever you want